Republicans are expressing confidence
about a new last-ditch effort to replace
parts of Obamacare the Trump
administration said yesterday that it is
all in on a plan devised by South
Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham and
Louisiana Senator Bill Cassidy it would
eliminate Affordable Care Act insurance
subsidies and gives States a lump sum to
create their own health care systems I'm
trying to take the money and power and
Washington and send it back closer to
the patient chief congressional
correspondent Nancy Cordes is here so
Nancy what do we know does it have a
chance of passing it really does have a
chance in order remember that the last
GOP health care bill failed thanks to a
last-minute no vote by Senator John
McCain back then he argued the bill
hadn't been subjected to a single
hearing well guess what they have set up
a hearing on this plan for this coming
Monday and McCain's vote is now very
much in play unlike the previous repeal
plans this bill would not eliminate all
of Obamacare taxes what it would do is
turn that revenue from those taxes over
to the states to then come up with their
own systems for boosting coverage and
depending on the state people with
pre-existing conditions could once again
pay more funding for Obama cares federal
insurance subsidies and Medicaid
expansion would end soon in 2020 and
Republicans Nora would need to round up
the votes for this plan by the end of
next week because that's the deadline
for voting with 60 rather than 50
senators Wow another big vote will be
watching Nancy thank you so much